you will end the legal obligation
to wear a face covering to mask or not
to mask
now a personal choice and a decision for
business owners like johnny
as much as they're a pain to to be
wearing especially for us
14 16 hour day um
we were wearing them for a reason i've
got some
serious thinking to do and for
performers like belinda scandal
the lifting of limits on capacity and
social distancing
offers a chance to return to the
spotlight having like full capacity
having people
you know being able to move and freely
move
it's it's mega because people will be
able to enjoy themselves and that's
the atmosphere that you crave from a pub
that you crave from a club
checking in will not be legally required
but it is another responsibility
for pubs and restaurants they will be
able to operate at full capacity
and people will be allowed to walk up to
bars and order drinks
small changes that could make a huge
difference
the changes will likely see more people
using public transport
as they return to offices but there are
concerns
about what that could mean for those who
are more vulnerable
you can't really control people's
decisions and
you can't really tell them what to do
but as for me i'm going to protect
myself
and the people in my household and i
will wear my mask i think
is the right thing for boris johnson to
do now
to just let people live their life
the pm's decision met with stark
warnings too from the uk's top
union which represents tens of thousands
of public transport workers
they say mask wearing should remain
compulsory
the mayor for greater manchester wants
the government to rethink
the removal of this requirement i think
could lead to some tension some
argument on public transport and as i
say many people
who've got some form of vulnerability
feeling very very uncomfortable
i love you care homes have suffered from
both the virus
and long lasting restrictions while
residents will be able to see more
visitors going forward
the new guidance means some measures
remain mass are a psychological barrier
to us being personalized care so that
when they see a smile
it means something we've gotten used to
living with masks
an extra item we pocket as we head out
and as we fully open up
many will leave them behind but moving
forward
plenty remain concerned about the impact
this may have
on our battle against the virus in zaman
rashid sky news
manchester